[Music]  it's gargantuan seven storied structure  with no apparent rhyme or reason built  on the orders of a grieving widow Sara  Winchester's mind is chaotic as the  house itself were worried about her  sanity dr. price mrs. Winchester it's a  pleasure to finally meet you do you  believe in ghosts dr. price I do not  believe in anything I cannot see or  study I feel your presence in the air in  the wall it has found her mrs.  Winchester from wildin construction on  the spirit killed by the rifle we lock  them away 13 nails or seals the moon I  will do it whatever it takes to protect  my family  [Applause]  [Music]  the spirit is a power we've not seen  before starlight and dewdrops awaiting  your defeat  [Music]